[Musique]
les essentielles du sénat
la france a besoin d'une diplomatie
professionnels
cela faisait 20 ans que les personnels
du quai d'orsay ne s'était pas mis en
grève
le 2 juin 2022 de nombreux diplomates
ont manifesté contre la suppression du
corps diplomatique dans le cadre de la
réforme de la haute fonction publique
voulue par emmanuel macron
dans leur rapport quel avenir pour le
corps diplomatique fait au nom de la
commission des affaires étrangères jean
pierre grand et andré vallini demande la
suspension de cette réforme qui ouvre
les postes de responsabilité du quai
d'orsay à tous les administrateurs de
l'état
cette réforme obère les perspectives de
carrières des personnels du ministère
qui le rejoignent par vocation et
fragilise l'appareil diplomatique
français qui a déjà perdu 50 % de ses
effectifs en 30 ans
la réforme a pour objectif de
diversifier le recrutement
pourtant le ministère de l'europe et des
affaires étrangères se caractérise déjà
par une forte ouverture 19% des
ambassadeurs et 41 % des chefs de
services de ce ministère ne sont pas des
diplomates
suspendre l'application de la réforme
est nécessaire pour ouvrir un dialogue
avec les personnels du ministère et les
commissions parlementaires
la réforme ne pourra être appliquée sans
nuire à l'appareil diplomatique qu'à la
condition de mettre en oeuvre les huit
recommandations de la commission des
affaires étrangères visant à préserver
l'efficacité de l'outil diplomatique
français dans une période caractérisée
par la reprise de la guerre en europe
principal garde-fous demandé par les
rapporteurs étendre le dispositif de
consultation des commissions
parlementaires permanentes aux
nominations des grands ambassadeurs
qu'il s'agisse de ceux du g20 ou de ceux
des organisations internationales
les sénateurs souhaitent en outre
garantir la sanctuarisation de
l'appartenance au quai d'orsay des
secrétaires des affaires étrangères
accédant au rang d'encadrement supérieur
de l'état
ils veulent également s'assurer que la
commission d'aptitude en cas de primo
nomination d'un chef de mission
diplomatique soit toujours composé pour
moitié des personnels issus des rangs du
ministère des affaires étrangères ou
ayant exercé les fonctions de chef de
mission diplomatique pendant au moins
cinq ans
pour découvrir l'ensemble des
recommandations de la commission des
affaires étrangères consultez la
synthèse du rapport
[Musique]